Today, we have something much requested by
the audience.
We are going to be speaking with Varsh, not
Vash, not the oche, but Varsh, a popular streamer
debater, progressive socialist with nearly
300000 subscribers.
Now, I think it's important my audience understands
that I don't call people socialists when they're
not socialist.
You're an actual bona fide socialist.
Yeah, I'd like to think I am at least cool.
Well, we'll get into that.
And now what?
I'm always curious, any time I deal with anybody
who uses a pseudonym.
How did you decide to operate under a pseudonym?
I was a big old art kid back in high school.
You know, every art kid wants to draw comics,
or at least a lot of them do.
OK is the name of a character that I wanted
to draw.
Anyway, when I started doing the content,
I just decided to use it as a placeholder
name and it stuck.
So that's catchy enough.
And I'm guessing for privacy reasons, it's
not the worst thing.
Oh, sure.
Yeah, but I mean, people go either way, but
I think it's nice and catchy anyway, so I
don't mind.
So let's let's talk a little bit.
I mean, maybe to get into our conversation,
we are coming off the heels of an election
in which Donald Trump lost Joe Biden won Senate
control.
Is that at this point?
And we're sort of trying to figure out what
what is the next step for someone with your
perspective as a socialist, where both Joe
Biden and Donald Trump are very different
from you in terms in terms of their politics?
Do you see replacing Trump with Biden as a
good thing?
How good of a thing?
Oh, undeniably, this is something that I learned
when I looked into the writings of people
like Engels and Lenin and Mao.
Is he socialists are, at least, as I understand
it, most comfortable making our arguments
in a democratic or a bourgeois democratic
system.
That is to say, in a system where we have
sort of this veneer of corporate democracy,
where people expect things like rights and
representation, you can make arguments like,
hey, couldn't we be doing this better in outright
fascist societies or societies which have
become so nationalistic that national interest
takes precedence over class interest?
It's really difficult to get those arguments
across.
That's why we typically lose whenever fascists
take power, we're the first ones out, we're
the biggest threat.
So preserving the system for a little bit
longer under Joe Biden, vastly, vastly preferable
to the threat of our democratic institutions
crumbling.
Also, just frankly, Biden's just better look
objectively at a number of issues.
Climate change, health care.
Can't argue with that.
So very clearly, you're making you're making
it obvious that you are not an acceleration
as the acceleration ism being the idea that
there would be a shortcut to your eventual
ideal arrangement of of affairs by having
society crumble, by having those institutions
crumble, that that would in some way accelerate
or more quickly get us to that endpoint.
You very clearly don't subscribe to that.
The conditions need to be right for that.
If things collapsed right now, we would not
be the ones to take power.
We do not have that kind of infrastructure
established.
They would be the ones to take power in a
system where it felt like chaos or collapse
would be something which would inspire some
kind of, you know, natural, organic, democratic
control.
I could get behind that.
But that is not the world we live in right
now.
What would happen in your mind if things crumbled
instead of a socialist utopia?
What would we most likely see?
Oh, man.
I mean, if things I mean, depending on how
things crumbled right now, the general prevailing
attitude in this country is fear and nationalism.
We would probably set up some sort of, if
not one singular, at least a collection of
ethno nationalist communities.
The direction this country is taking right
now, the world is controlled, at least in
chaos, by the most militarily prepared.
And right now, I think a large number of Trump
supporters are ready.
They believe they're on the precipice of having
to take hold of a dead world, whereas a lot
of progressive and left leaning people, you
know, God bless them, whatever, I don't think
are ready for that.
And for that reason, if push comes to shove,
I'm just not confident that our chances I
think that we're going to go dramatically
far.
Right.
I think we're probably going to turn into
an isolationist ethno nationalist state and
from that point forward will be completely
unable to affect the rest of the world as
its course changes.
And I don't I don't want that.
Yeah, OK.
So so far, I completely agree with you.
I think that if we do see a crumbling that
some imagine might lead to the ushering in
of the idealized socialist circumstances,
I think we get exactly what you're talking
about now.
Under what circumstances do you believe that
your socialist organization of the country
would be most likely to be achieved?
What would happen between now and then leading
up to it?
We need to do a lot of cultural work and we
need to get people to.
Fixate on issues that actually affect their
lives.
What gets a Trump supporter out of bed, what
gets them angry at the world, is that the
state of their schools, their infrastructure,
their education, their health care.
Very rarely.
No, usually it's meaningless cultural issues.
You have trans people.
You have the belief that BLM is going to burn
down their suburb.
These are nonsense, scaremongering, fear issues.
These aren't reflective of reality.
And for that reason, this is why we are concern
ourselves with the spread of something called
class consciousness.
We want people to be concerned first and foremost
with the conditions that actually affect their
lives.
And if we can do that, and I believe we can
do that and people like Bernie Sanders have
shown you can do that to lots of people if
you focus on the right arguments, I think
that will be in a position where the predominant
ideological trend of this country will be
one towards radical workplace democracy as
opposed to radical isolationism, radical ethnic
exclusionary behavior, that sort of thing.
Am I being too simplistic if I say that for
the time being, socialists and Social Democrats
should be united because the next steps are
identical for both groups?
Or at least they should be?
No, I think that's totally true.
I mean, will backstab each other later, right?
Strickly?
Yeah, of course.
Of course.
But for right now, yeah.
We need to focus on Social Democrats.
You consider yourself one.
Of course.
I do know the war.
Yeah.
Because a senior content, Social Democrats
and socialists have a lot in common and that
we both respect the belief that the economic
resources of our country should be turned
towards the well-being of the people.
We should focus on improving these base institutional
needs that we believe humans are entitled
to.
And that's great.
And I think that when people are exposed to
that, they're way less likely to associate
their well-being with these meaningless cultural
platitudes that Trump supporters or other
culture warriors like to obsess over.
For now, I think our interests are aligned
down the line.
You know, we'll have our arguments, I'm sure.
So now let's think ahead a little bit.
If we just to really kind of continue exploring
your your worldview, imagine that the Social
Democrats get the things they want.
We have democratization of the workplace.
We are sort of raising the floor and putting
some ceiling in and make sure making sure
nobody falls too far and doing some of the
things Finland and other northern European
places have done.
Social Democrats get their way.
OK, once you get to that point.
What mechanism do you imagine would usher
in socialism, how do we get to where every
business, for example, socializes ownership
of the means of production?
By what mechanism is that installed or enacted?
Well, you mentioned workplace democracy, which
I like.
I think those are very good Trojan horse for
socialist ideals, because it literally is
the seizure of the means of production in
a society in which every workplaces democratic.
That is to say, there are some there is some
kind of democratic framework that allows you
to vote in or vote out individuals, managers,
that sort of thing.
And the means of those firms, the wealth,
the resources are collectively owned among
those who work there.
If you have every firm in a country that adheres
to those principles, you have what would have
been called one hundred and fifty years ago,
a dictatorship of the proletariat, not very
well named, but essentially because dictatorship
didn't have the connotation back then that
it does now a workers state.
Well, let me let's pause for a second there.
Maybe we might have a different idea of what
in fact, it's very clear we have a different
idea of what democratization of the workplace
would mean.
So when I think about democratization of the
workplace, I'm talking about four companies
above a certain size.
You must have broad representation from employees
when you so there's a list of things.
But I think it's probably it certainly doesn't
sound like it would go as far as what you're
talking about, which sounds like it would
almost be a socialization of the means of
production.
That would be the goal for me at least.
I think that a democratically minded people
are very susceptible to arguments in favor
of the democratization of the workplace in
the way that I describe it.
Yeah, I think that once you look at a firm
and you look at its traditional organization,
which is pretty dictatorial in its natural
state, you know, here in the States, you don't
control who your manager is or your bosses.
You work there and you do what you're told
or you're fired.
I think that people are very amicable to the
idea that there can be an improvement on that
system.
There's very, very positive data coming out
of countries well all around the world and
different material conditions suggesting that
worker cooperatives are a pretty effective
way of organizing firms.
And it leaves people happier.
And in some cases it's even more efficient.
So the question is, how can we sell people
on the idea that that system, which necessitates
the destruction of the bourgeoisie, the class,
you no longer have an owner after all, it's
collective.
How do we incentivize that?
How do we encourage people to move in that
direction?
But is your view so there's a dramatic difference
between everybody is convinced and sold on
the idea that that's how businesses should
be owned versus it is imposed as this is how
it must be done or otherwise it is not a legal
business.
It sounds like you're leaning, at least for
now, more in the direction of saying you feel
like you have the facts on your side and you
could convince people to do it that way.
Are you not suggesting that at a certain point
the only legal way to organize a business
would be socialized ownership?
I don't think you can compel democracy.
I don't think it works very well.
I think that when socialism arrives in the
states, should it arrive, nobody will call
it socialism.
They will view it as a natural extension of
a series of economic and worker related rights
that they've been building upon it for a good
time before that.
With regards to whether or not this should
be pushed for in an autocratic way, though,
an autocratic sort of delivery of democracy
is a little little silly.
But it's happened before.
Yes.
When we freed the slaves, of course, the slave
owners didn't like that, but we did it anyway.
And I think we can agree that was a good thing.
The people who will be pushing back on this
aren't going to be the democratic populace.
It's probably going to be the owners of these
businesses.
And that's the ultimate conflict.
You know, how well how significantly can the
interests of the majority be assigned precedence
over the interests of a very small, very elite
group of landed modern aristocrats?
We're going to continue our conversation with
Vashion in the full interview will be posted
on the YouTube channel.
But on the podcast, TV and radio show, we
are going to go to
a break.
The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.